sonum obsession how are you hi i'm i'm
all right are you okay you have a rough
night you've got these twins now yeah no
i'm fine i mean uh up until like a
minute ago one of them was screaming
downstairs and i was like should i get
up and then i didn't and now i feel like
i'm a big mom
no no just because your child was
screaming for you
and you were
maybe 15 feet away and decided that a
podcast was more important doesn't make
you a bad mother
thank you you really reassured me thanks
so much yeah no i'm sure
someone else will maybe get some food
some food for that child or
change its wet diaper before he gets a
terrible rash someone else will handle
that probably or he'll figure it out
himself anyway moving on um
matt gourley you also have a newborn my
god my whole team
fertile
that was
that was not what i was going to say but
yes yes you're both very fertile i have
a fertile squad um
maybe it's you i mean maybe you're the
aphrodisiac i think i am i think no no
it is true sorry i had to jump in there
no i heard no yeah you had these babies
in spite of you yeah
conan o'brien and the fertile chill
chunks
you noticed that we both know in his
fertile friends children on a break from
this podcast that's right
your birth yes but that's true when you
briefly got away from me during kovid
you both instantly created human life
because you were you were away from
the
[Laughter]
the anti-baby uh anti-life force that is
conan o'brien yeah wow that's
you made my ovaries clamp up oh for
god's sake
my testicles were up in my throat
i used to see them whenever you do opera
scales
um you'd go like me me me me me me huh
and i go look out i see your [ __ ]
oh my god it's happening now what yeah
oh stop it you know what i don't like if
we want another child you are fine with
the testicles you're not okay with the
ovaries can i just is that what's
happening i think that's fair i'm used
to seeing testicles um
they're a big part of my life
that well they are i mean they're just
everywhere
that's going to be on your tombstone
yeah o'brien fine with the testicles not
so much the overalls yeah in parenthesis
1963. yeah
uh
yeah conor bryant
fine with the testicles parentheses
not so much with the ovaries
i just i i guess i i um yeah it's a
mystery to me
the working
workings of the female system uh so yes
but when you say ovaries clamped up it
just i didn't like it i didn't like the
visual of like these two clamps coming
down and crushing ovaries it just was
upset me but you're okay with like
with gourley's testicles going up into
his body yeah well they do first of all
testicles do that when you're in cold
water things get they shrink and then uh
if it's really cold or if you're really
scared in moments in my life where i've
been really scared the first time i
hosted a major award show um my package
went up into my body that's something
that it actually happens it went up into
my body and it stayed there i think from
i'm gonna say 2002 to 2006.
oh no
it was i was told it was normal and
the only way to get them back down is to
jump off um a high
height and and hit the ground hard
with both feet and then they come
shooting back down again
and the noises
yes you jump and you just put my
testicles
and then
oh man
finally some sunlight and i went quiet
you it's about time you came out well
i was kind of worried about coming out
and so i thought i'd hang out in the old
chess cavity
well it's good to have you back old
friend well it's good to be back oh boy
it's not easy being up inside your chest
well i don't want to hear any more
complaining out of you testicles now
let's get going okay if you're sure
i'm sure i'll just put my pants on
please make them
boxers there's just more air
nope it's tiny whities today
not the tiny whities i get all crushed
up
you'll take it and like it testicles
oh no
you realize i could do this for four
hours yeah that's why i'd better flash
the rap sign yeah probably good to stop
now and yeah
probably good to stop now
hey testicles oh i get my own podcast
yeah
when do i get to broadcast i've got a
lot of things to say
oh really yes do you do testicles yeah
how come you didn't use me much in the
80s and 90s shut up testicles
seems to me like you blew some
opportunities
shut up testicles all right but wait'll
i write my books
my guest today there's no transition